está con nosotros en el estudio
nuevamente lluís Muñoz Luis bienvenido
Comencemos cuál medio comenzamos en New
York Times Hola de nuevo si estamos
hemos empezado con América Latina en esa
primera franja horaria vamos a
centrarnos ahora con el bloque
occidental y cómo ya ha acabado el día
en Europa y cerca de acabarse en Estados
Unidos Cómo han sido esas portadas de
los principales diarios En este caso New
York Times uno de los periódicos más
importantes del mundo Qué dice así año
en guerra Estados Unidos anuncia más
ayuda para Ucrania y sanciones a Rusia
durante todo el día como comentábamos
han estado pues dando voz
lensky que recogen en uno de los
subtítulos van a dice algo así como van
a ganar la guerra y sobre todo si
permanecen Unidos como un puño todos los
aliados de Ucrania también hacen énfasis
en el nuevo paquete de 2000 millones de
dólares que ha prometido Estados Unidos
en ayuda militar Y ya se acerca a los
60.000 millones de dólares en ayudas a
Ucrania que es similar al presupuesto de
defensa que tuvo Rusia en 2021 además
también recogen pues esas sanciones
conjuntas de Estados Unidos en la Unión
Europea contra Rusia durante todo el día
también New York Times ha tenido
distintos reportajes interesantes
destaca uno de la energía que es una de
las de las grandes consecuencias que ha
habido en este primer año de conflicto
en Europa se esperaba que este invierno
iba a ser Mucho más duro pero consideran
que el invierno no ha sido no han tenido
unas condiciones climáticas tan extremas
y además china con las restricciones de
covid-19 pues esos dos factores han
hecho que no hayan sido tan tan notorias
las consecuencias de esa crisis
energética sobre todo en Europa pasamos
al país el principal diario en lengua
española en el mundo que tienen un
reportaje especial que ha estado
titulando todo el día que dice cómo
Putin ha desatado la guerra más global
desde
recogen bien al principio del artículo
las palabras de josep burrell El jefe de
la diplomacia de la Unión Europea que ha
dicho algo así como que no es una guerra
mundial sino que estamos ante una guerra
mundiallizada dentro del artículo
también hacen pues hablan de la
dimensión militar económica geopolítica
humanitaria y como Aunque hay 50 países
que condenan la invasión rusa a Ucrania
solo hay 40 que sancionan y 30 países
que son los que han enviado armamento
por último para acabar este este flanco
este este bloque occidental tenemos el
kit post que más allá de recoger todo lo
que ha estado diciendo celiamski durante
el día las sanciones etcétera tienen un
reportaje bastante especial que se llama
un año sin que son distintos testimonios
de distintas personas ucranianas como
Pues un año sin piernas un año sin casa
un año sin paternidad un año sin bailar
un año En definitiva sin Ucrania un año
muy difícil para todos yo hice Vamos a
continuar con esta revisión de los
medios Estados Unidos no reveló
evidencia de suministro de armas chinas
a la federación de Rusia y esto
es un medio ruso de los más leídos y
todo el día están cambiando de titular
constantemente es este es el último que
han recogido pero también durante el día
han recogido otros como el embajador en
Canadá ole que este acusado de
impotencia rusofoba estas sanciones
conjuntas que se han anunciado de la
Unión Europea de Estados Unidos de
Canadá también ha estado como ha estado
analizando nuestra analista Pues también
han recogido esa conversación telefónica
entre erdogan y Putin donde se buscan
pues esas negociaciones que hay
multilaterales para llegar a una fin del
conflicto
pasamos ahora a Rusia today en inglés
que titula como una noticia de última
hora que es mayores de la otan plantean
plan de negociaciones para Ucrania una
información que es de Wall Street
journal y al parecer lo que recoger
Rusia today que es uno de los medios que
están ahora mismo que no se pueden ver
tanto en Europa como en Estados Unidos
en esta guerra mediática que hay es que
Reino Unido Francia y Alemania han
acordado envío de armas Ucrania a cambio
de que se leensky tenga una una mayor
predisposición a iniciar las
negociaciones y este envío de armas es
visto como una forma de que también
pueda vender dentro de Ucrania ese
inicio de conversaciones como una
victoria política y por último vamos con
el global Times de China que titula
china insta a un alto el fuego entre
Rusia y Ucrania ofrece un camino hacia
la paz en un documento de posición en
una de las noticias del día que es ese
acuerdo de 12 Bueno ese ese documento de
12 puntos en el que china pues propone
ese alto el fuego al inicio de las
negociaciones pero que Rusia Aunque dice
estar dispuesto a escucharlo ha dicho
que no van a aceptar esa territorialidad
Luis Muchas gracias por este completo
resumen de lo que titulan los
principales medios internacionales y
medios chinos y de Rusia también